we have a justice system for reason and
we have amendments that are that are
alleged to or ostensibly supposed to
prevent the federal government from
doing things like putting people on
list I do like pulling the student visas
though if you're not an American citizen
I don't think you're entitled to the
same you know sort of uh you know us
being careful with your rights okay if
you're not from here and you're showing
us even the possibility that you're
going to align with Terror like you're
good to go we're going to we're going to
ask you to leave I do love he said
Tucker Elon and Rogan hosting the debate
10 times the viewership 10 bro it would
be like 300
to
AC we stopped
any going on either against Jewish
Americans in New Jersey or Muslim
Americans in New Jersey it takes
leadership Lester to know how to do this